what's with the jeans yeah so there's um
this I've been wanting to show you yeah
we have so much to share there's so much
today I've collected materials you've
collected oh he's back
so this max we haven't played him in a
while but he's in the news did you know
he's in the new now I'll get to that
just to give you an idea yes this is
Bryan Silva otherwise known as a vine
star yeah who rolls in swag and he makes
he made a lot of videos yeah talking
about how dope he is and you know I'll
take your girl and yeah doing this thing
stuff like that he's doing the thing
he's really into his body and his
physique and his oh it's really looks
great it's always like by the way you
know as a fat guy nothing irritates me
more than somebody who's super super
thin and goes like I'm super muscular no
you know you're just really skinny I
like his body you do I'd like to have it
oh you mean he's got like a lady's body
it's a nice figure yeah yeah it's not
even a regular body it's like it's the
kind of guy who I look at and I think
what a nice figure that's what yeah like
a lady that's what I'm saying I wouldn't
mind having a teenage boys physique
that's nice for a lady here's what um
here's to give you to familiarize you
with his brain work here's a little
backstory out here's a little bit of
what he used to put up okay
yeah he's hollow tips to be on your
dinner plate I keep a full clip on my
hip that would knock you off the map
yeah duh
on the sideways nigga I'll leave your
head only dump laptop what's gonna bitch
swag okay this man yeah you met some guy
nigga you know he drops big words and
you sure does gets away with it well uh
you might that might change pretty soon
okay there's a little bit of news I
guess I was mentioning that will make
you reconsider your language here is
some news that aired about mr. Silva
over the Silva is the man who
surrendered to Charlottesville police
following a multiple hour standoff on
Sunday the 25 year old would not talk
about what led up to the dispute nor why
he barricaded himself in the house Bryan
Silva
exceptin NBC 29 s request for an
interview at the jail we SH so he's
being they shouldn't clip of him being
asked so I guess he held somebody in the
home at gunpoint
and here he's being asked cord with his
pants around his knee I'm surprised he's
25 more than anything I thought this kid
was like 17 well not knowing what to
expect and all Silva would say is free
me over and over again today Silva stuck
to a single message would not address
why he took to social media and posted
videos while barricaded inside that
house hmm so yeah as he was held up in
this house he posted multiple videos you
know like there's the cops the house
stuff like this pretty good shout oh
I'll give them that
yeah his black voice is on fleek it's
pretty good I mean it could maybe we
could use some of it for Tom or black
Tom or black or Bryan Silva or mr. white
folks mr. white folks I'm a
motherfucking caboose
yes ol Amos dude he's so dumb this kid
the dumbest yeah he's pretty bad and
that's funny he went from that free me
free me right like I'm just gonna why he
is just a big mix-up mm-hmm I love the I
love a guy who's talking the most shit
to himself he's out of his mind
you think he's on meth he's he's ha some
sounds wrong he's high as fuck I think
you know math makes you real paranoid
and like remember they Henri our old
driver it was like I would do math and
just look for the people no there's a
lot of crack oh that was
yeah yeah ha yeah there goes my theory
yeah I don't know I think he's a little
jacked up on something maybe yeah dude
hey hey Lee ain't got shit fuck nigga
he's not retarded you think it's
fighting with Abby no I swear to god yo
yeah this was right there I swear to God
I gotta follow this guy in the vine
these are great you don't have to hey
this is down to 7% that is it looks like
it is over here no it's not that matter
it's doing okay yeah yeah good looking
at look good look huh he just freely
uses the end bomb like that he thinks
he's black that's the craziest part yes
he's 25 years old and he calls himself
the n-word yeah you got he gave himself
permission that's for sure do you think
he calls white people Caucasians
probably you wouldn't know about that as
you Caucasian he's like he's under he's
under privilege yeah you know he's one
of those you're probably right he
probably was all these Caucasian my
fucking through yeah he identifies as
being uh you know discriminated against
yes I don't know how but it's it's
certainly some chance Bryan prices kind
of makes you go and what I want to do is
for us to come yeah